Opening up these coffins and photographing them...
...has been something we've wanted to do for a long, long time.
These have been in vitrines, and they've only received some sporadic attention.
Thanks to a generous grant from the dean's competitive fund,...
...we've been able to open up the vitrines...
...and assemble an all-star cast of conservators, professional photographers,...
...pigment sampling and residue and wood analysis experts.
They've come from as far away as University College in London...
...and from our own Strauss Center here at the Harvard Art Museum.
And so, we're trying to do everything we can in the way of documentation and study.
These coffins come from Thebes, modern Luxor, several hundred miles south of Cairo.
There are no bodies, no mummies, in any of the three.
The other two are wooden coffins with beautiful painted decorations.
So, they belong to Pa-di-mut, to Ankh Kohnsu and Mut iy-iy,...
...two men and one woman.
We knew we had to proceed very carefully and slowly with lifting the lids of the coffins.
This research has a two-fold implication, where we're creating models...
...for researchers, for scholars and also for visitors to a museum,...
...and you can use them as teaching tools.
This project ties into our general mission here at the museum,...
...which is to enhance our teaching collection...
...with all kinds of new technologies.